hallo leute jetzt wieder einmal war und
weg zu einem neuen video haltet färbe
ich meinem bruder wie die haare and
value nico gefahr so dass wir geschichte
in der aus
so kommen wir erst mal zudem warum warum
warum reden wir dieses video warum teure
wohnten hier bauern bist machen muss und
ob der hand drauf das problem ist er hat
mir die aufgabe gegeben
diese verantwortung zu übernehmen
sie haben fragen kann nur sagen es war
marks tod zu diesem leben einfach echt
überlegen einfach berkshire aus mit
ihnen sprechen
du hast mit dem kieker hat manchmal so
lebensweisheiten wo er den ich nicht
weiß woher sie kommen aber am kreuzweg
im leben wir wollten ja die geliebten
falls ihr sprüche welche von meinem
bruder haben von hilfen bereit
dass bettencourt und ein büro gerne in
die kommentare moment du bist jetzt im
friseursalon ja hallo ich wurde gerufen
ja ich meine gebote gehörten rund folge
an und mancher ja aber tief unten drin
sarah muss ein termin bei mir gemacht
oder heute abend es ist der 25
oktober also ich sag jetzt mal welche
farbe wir gesucht haben wie haltet
perlmutt mittelblond und damit wir bloß
den gelbstich vermeiden habe ich noch
silber chapeau gekauft also die haben
jungfräuliches haar das bedeutet
die einfärbung drin richtig das mache
jetzt einmal vorher schutz von dir dann
kommst du in die zauberkugel sie ist
danach komme ich wollte gut aus wir
haben hier kann man clayton ist die
farbe fertig so schnell die kamera sie
tanzen willst du denn die mir schon auf
dem trockenen unbescheiden entscheidet
muss ihr können an design lässt die
mischung zu hören habe 21 minuten sollte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich nicht
es geht los
machte das die farbe vom kopf her
gespannt heute muss es gerade so
wirklich glaube ich habe aufgehört zu
atmen ich noch nervös bin
stinkt das zeug nicht vorher müssen sich
dann auch noch da muss ich noch deine
augenbrauen wieder korrigieren und das
du na ja noch duschen
aha und dann müssen wir dann nachher
sehen woher so mache anderes
thomas anders heute kommen und gucken
wie es aussieht ok mal gehört dass davon
dürfte dazu führen dass wir werden nicht
einfach nur als gesamt und böse menschen
dazu sagen also brauchst du auf jeden
fall ein
obwohl ihr um hitze hat den kopfseiten
so gespannter bisschen gebrannt und
bisschen denker gründen das was würde
passieren wenn eine mütze auf dem kopf
jetzt haben wir eine tüte draufgelegt
also siehst ja jetzt habe ich deine
machnig
wir lassen das jetzt ein will einblick
in diese schöne farbe und dann kommen
wir gleich wieder bevor wir's ausspielen
damit euch genau so so freunde wie ist
der stand genau da genau und jetzt
gucken wir mal du hast du drauf geworden
und so hab ja der kopf ist
doch der muss warm sein beim blondieren
damit die farbe aktiviert wird man muss
halt nur ganz kurz gemeckert über unser
vorhaben die haare zu berge für ihre
verhältnisse war das meckern wirklich
auf ganz kleinem niveau
für sie war dunkel aus das heißt noch
nicht ja recht sagen dass sie nicht so
du alles ist schön geworden also näher
als richtiger da das auf keinen fall
ja ich weiß nicht was dann ja weiter sie
ist irgendwie sofort klar wir können
gerne noch eine heitere momente
welchen breitgetreten dreileben
lustigerweise sieht man es in der kamera
so gar nicht gar nicht aber gleich sieht
man es besser ich will sie es nicht tun
du aus
wir sind wir
pauli
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dusche sein was rasch dieses zeug aus
dem haus raus und dann geht es los
also am projekt das war so bist du weißt
was du hast so ein schönes helles brown
jetzt sieht man der kamera natürlich
beiden haare noch nass sind ein
wichtiger sagt marianne braun
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das was du am meisten
liebsten nach altem brauch auf gefühle
[Musik]
haben ja jetzt bekommst eine
gesichtsmaske alle eine gesichtsmaske
also ich lege da wird auch dein gesicht
das ist eine maske warum für hütte
ration kann sein vielleicht wieder so
weit reichen
das ist so
das ist so ganz ins gesicht fassen
umgehen
[Musik]
eigentlich sollte es anders besser oder
wollte zum großen ein steak war es nicht
das nächste mal hast du das wiederholen
werden müssen wir so extrem noch mehr
sponsoring winkel und singen wie ein
krieger und das bereits für die
liebkosung sind wir bereits ist nachher
damit einen goldenen durch ein in den
haaren
allgemein
[Musik]
das timing ist natürlich ein bisschen
schwer bei der länge das ist ein
bisschen kurz und würden über zu machen
nachschaute was er will so schön oder
skippers kann ist sehr schön
ich hoffe auch ihr müsst ihr euch können
dass nichts sehen natürlich hat wieder
das video
wenn ihr eine extremere veränderung
sehen wollten
das war erstmals anfang und anfang
öffentlich zu ende
da würde sage ich und sie sagen tschüss
tschaikowsky
es war mir eine freude die leute darauf
angewiesen dass gold klischees